For decades, Intel has been the most
popular choice for CPUs, powering more
than half the world's computers. But
when they released their first GPU in
1998, the i740 was so poorly received
that they literally quit making GPUs for
24 years. Yes, it was actually that bad.
But after more than two decades, Intel
launched their new fastest GPU, the Ark
V580. And Intel claims that it can
handle both 1440p gaming at over 60fps
and ray tracing all for just
$250. Sounds too good to be true, right?
Well, there's only one way to find out.
To see if the Ark B580 really lives up
to Intel's claims, I decided to buy it
with my own money. Surprisingly, I
managed to get it for its retail price
of just
$249. But you might be wondering why it
took me so long to actually get my hands
on it, especially since the B580 was
released back in December of last year.
Well, only weeks after release, the B580
ran into serious issues. When paired
with weaker CPUs, even as strong as the
Ryzen 7600 nonX, performance was
abysmal. When you pair both GPUs in the
exact same game, but with an older CPU,
the B580 gets absolutely destroyed.
There was actually a title where even
the 7600 caused a slight dip in the 1%
lows. And that completely defeats the
purpose of a budget GPU. Because if you
need an expensive CPU just to make it
usable, what's the point? 4 months later
with new drivers, I'm hoping they fix
things because if they have, this might
be the best GPU under $300. Well, at
least until you consider the used
market, but we'll talk about that later.
First, I wanted to see if Intel's
fastest GPU can actually deliver the
1440p 60fps experience they promised.
So, to put Intel's claims to the test, I
tried 10 different games at 1440p to see
if the Arc B580 could prove itself as a
true 1440p graphics card. Starting with
one of the lighter games on the list,
Counter-Strike 2 on the 1440p high
preset scores an average of 170 FPS. But
apart from my horrible gameplay, the
thing that stands out the most is the
very high VRAM usage with the game
eating up nearly 11 GB of VRAM. So, it's
good to know that it's already in a
league of its own compared to the 8 GB
4060 and 7600. But since the B580 has 12
GB of VRAM, I had to put it to the test
with the most VRAM hungry games I own.
At 1440p very high settings, Ratchet and
Clank Rift Apart was using more VRAM
than the B580 comes with and still
averaged 68 FPS without any stuttering
or slowdowns, even in the most chaotic
fights with the craziest visual effects.
In one of the heaviest titles of this
video, Cyberpunk 2077 at 1440p high
settings also runs smoothly at about 69
FPS. In the heaviest game of this video,
Blackmth Wukong pushed this GPU to its
absolute limits. Keep in mind the 4090
only gets 70 fps at 1440p max settings
in this game. So the numbers we got with
the B580 will not impress you. I was
only getting 70 fps with the B580 at low
settings, which sounds decent compared
to the 4090 until you realize it's
actually 864p upscaled to 1440p. Goes to
show just how demanding these Unreal
Engine 5 games can get. However, these
are some of the newest games that I own.
So how does it stack up against some
older games? In Rise of the Tomb Raider,
at the very high preset with pure hair
maxed out, the game still runs very well
between 80 and 115 FPS depending on
where you are. At the high preset,
Shadow of the Tomb Raider ran smoothly
at 105 FPS at high settings, only
dropping to 90 FPS on the highest
preset. In cutscenes, close-ups, and
just less demanding areas in general,
though, you can expect really smooth
performance at around 100 FPS even on
the highest settings. At 1440p high,
control ran around 70 fps. In Frag Punk,
the newest game in this video, it ran at
100 FPS at native 1440p high. Elden
Ring, my most played game in the last
week, performed perfectly at 1440p max
settings, staying at 60fps with minimal
power usage, making it a perfect choice
for this game. But that's where the good
news ends, because I ran into some
pretty big problems in this very last
game, which was coincidentally the first
game I tried playing on the B580. In
Uncharted 4, the FPS was actually really
solid for the price between 80 and 90.
But as you could probably tell, the
recording looked completely unwatchable.
Luckily, just disabling hags in my
graphics settings fixed that. But there
were still problems that you will not
see in the recording. Every 30 seconds,
my second screen would flash white, and
my main monitor had strange black
squares, similar to the black squares
that you'll see with a dying GPU.
Strangely, this only happened in game.
It seemed like once the GPU was under a
certain amount of stress, both my
screens just start freaking out. So, I
thought maybe the newest drivers were
just bad. And for once, I was right
about something because rolling back to
the second latest driver fixed all my
problems instantly. And as you saw just
now, most of the games I tested in 1440p
went very smoothly on these drivers. So,
for the most part, it seems that Intel
wasn't lying about the 1440p
performance. But what about the rate
tracing? Intel made some bold claims
about the rateracing capabilities of
their flagship GPU. So, it would be a
crime to not talk about that next. But
if we learned anything from Nvidia's
four generations of RTX cards, it's that
ray tracing performance will almost
always be a disappointment. You ready?
You can watch my hand. You watch my
hand. Okay, I'm going to move
it. That's what that's that's what we're
seeing. So, will Intel be any better or
will they let us down too? Let's start
with a lighter example of rateracing
with Shadow of the Tomb Raider.
Ironically, the game only features ray
trace shadows, and even then, it still
drops our frames by 50% despite the game
looking virtually identical to what it
was before. But it gets worse because I
forgot to tell you one thing about what
Intel said about the RT on this GPU. A
huge part of their marketing relies on
their version of DLSS Super Resolution,
XCSS. And to hit that advertised 1440p
rate tracing performance, Intel expects
you to run XCSS in performance mode,
which means the game is actually
rendering at just 720p. So naturally,
the rest of the native 1440p benchmarks
didn't hold up nearly as well. In
Control, with high settings and the
lowest rate tracing preset, the Ark
can't even reach 50 FPS when we were
previously achieving 70 without RT.
Although native 1440p rateracing
performance is pretty underwhelming,
it's important to remember that the ARC
B580 is cheaper than both the 4060 and
7600, both of which were built for
1080p. And when we drop the resolution,
Intel's GPU can actually handle
rateracing. And compared to the 4060,
the gaming experience you're getting
with the B580 will almost always be
better. Now, at this point, we are all
aware that the Intel Arc B580 is a very
strong competitor to AMD and Nvidia's
current generation graphics cards. So,
what if we compare to something that's
already proven itself as the best budget
option under $300? And of course, I'm
talking about none other than the GTX
1080 Ti. Despite costing only an average
price of $170, it's able to keep up and
even outperform GPUs like the RTX 3060,
RTX 4060, and RX7600. So, is the B580
worth the $80 premium over the 1080 Ti?
Absolutely not. Earlier, I mentioned the
issue where the B580 struggles to run
properly with weaker CPUs. And somehow
even my 7600X still wasn't good enough
for it. You'll see that it wins in every
game except for Rocket League and
Fortnite. And that's because as the
frame rates get higher, the games rely
more on the CPU to queue in more frames.
As a result, the B580 loses its lead
against the 1080 Ti. And overall, it's
only about 18% better in average FPS
while being about 5% worse in the 1%
lows. Sure, if we turned on rate
tracing, the B580 would be miles ahead,
but that doesn't change the bigger
issue. For me to recommend an Intel Arc
GPU in 2025, they need to fix these
driver problems immediately. It's a
great GPU for the price. Matter of fact,
I think it's definitely one of the best
entry-level 1440p graphics cards, but
until Intel completely fixes their
driver issues, I can't confidently
recommend buying their GPUs yet. So, for
now, you're better off going with Nvidia
or AMD and maybe even both at the same
time. So, if you want to see me use both
Nvidia and AMD in the same PC to get 240
FPS in every game, watch this video
next.